[Music]
[Music]
hello hello hi how are you guys I am
here oh is it working is it working
oh is it not working it better be
working
I hope it's working okay it's working
okay hi guys I am I'm the worst as you
might have noticed from the title I am
the absolute worst I have and not for
the reasons you're thinking you're all
thinking that like oh this is just some
other thing that marks done obviously we
all knew this this is old news at this
point I I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up real bad I [ __ ] up real
real real real bad real bad
I [ __ ] up real bad so I won't get into
it immediately I'll talk about in just a
second it won't take long
but I I [ __ ] up but in summary before
I [ __ ] up I was gonna come here and do
a livestream in I was gonna say hey I've
been gone for two months here's me
catching you all up - what I've been on
but now I [ __ ] up like last night like
last night I [ __ ] up I did I did bad
everything else was gonna be fine and
dandy everything was gonna be great
like I was I was ready to like come in
have a fun stream everything was gonna
be great
everything was gonna be hunky-dory
everything was gonna be everything was
gonna be wonderful but um so I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up but well I'll get to that in
just a second because people are still
streaming in here and I I want to like
admit it in front of the largest
audience possible that I [ __ ] up so
I've been away for two months right I've
been in Austin I and I'll talk about
this in great length after I admit how I
[ __ ] up but hey it's good to see you
guys I'm back in LA now and I'm back in
my recording room and it's good to be
back with my recording setup my sound
treated room my my good computer here
and everything working hopefully but I
I've been back since Monday night last
week and I've been getting slowly on my
feet again and everything's been going
good and I've been working on
post-production for this project that I
was filming and everything was going
great I had a good weekend I took like a
day off yesterday I really relaxed but I
[ __ ] up last night so I it's a real
short story but you guys will see about
how I [ __ ] up so amy was spending time
with her friends out and about and you
know she was gonna come back later later
last night way late and so I went to bed
before she got back she just so happens
to not have her key to the house on her
because she didn't she took it off her
keyring when she we went out toss sixth
he was like I don't want to leave it in
Austin just in case so she didn't have
her key on her so I said I texted her
hey I left the side door unlocked for
you so you know go to bed so I must have
muscle memory relocked it to bed and I I
went to bed and you know like Amy and my
phone she's in my favorites list like
she's there apparently like even if even
if it's on do not disturb because I have
a bedtime and I'm like my phone's on
silent and so on do not disturb
apparently if it's on your favorites
list it's supposed to bring anyway but
it didn't so I'll give you a little
timetable I go to bed like midnight and
that's a late night for me going to bed
at midnight that's layer that's weekend
staying up so I'm like whoo that's a
late night I gotta hit the old sack I'm
gonna go to bed so then I text her like
side doors unlock Bible blah blah love
you bye and then she's like oh it's okay
I'll be back in 45 or so minutes you
know I'll see you later I'm like that's
fine goodnight
kissy-face moji whatever and so if she
gets home and she tries the side door
and that's locked so that's this she's
like oh maybe it was maybe it was
another side door around the garage and
that door opened so that was great but
the door to go from the garage into the
house was locked so she may have spent
the night sleeping in the van
you know the barrel - it's in my garage
so she called me 10 times last night
that should be a bunch and bless her
heart she took it in stride she she
found like some some pillow cases no
pillows there were no pillows in the in
the van she found some pillow cases like
laying about the garage she used one
pillow case as a sheet and she used the
other one like folded up as a pillow and
I didn't know this I was I was in
Snoozeville snoring away dreaming happy
dreams and so I wake up and you know I
get up usually early but I went to bed
late so I get up like 7:30 I'm like all
over and you know I see Amy's not there
so I look up my phone and I'm like dude
time to check the morning news and just
just like message after message after
call after call after call it's like oh
so I sprint downstairs in my underwear
and I fling open the door and I'm just
like pierrot Amy and she pops her head
out of the van like oh you're not dead
just look
no she wasn't mad that's the thing she
was not mad and that's like I can't
fathom that like I felt so bad I felt so
bad so bad but you know she is just so
nice she's sleeping now
I should be quieter she's sleeping now
and and just like I felt so unbelievably
bad but she took it in so much stride so
I'm like I need you guys to lambast me
lambaste I need you guys to roast me
alive I need you guys to publicly shame
II shame shame II shame me for what I
did last night see this is not a
clickbait title this isn't clickbait at
all
I am literally the war so she didn't
sleep a lot in the van because it as it
turns out it's not very comfortable and
there's an automatic light sensor in the
garage so if there's even the slightest
movement the light flips on so she is
apparently every time she rolled over or
something in the fan it would just shake
the van just the tiniest bit and then
the light would flick on so this just it
was just a night of torment and I feel I
need you guys to please publicly shame
me like report me to all the drama
channels blow this up in a big way I owe
her so much I I said I promised her like
I just a vacation or something because
that's apparently anyway so that is that
is how I [ __ ] up last night
but-but-but-but bud bud bud but that's
not the point of this stream it's kind
of the point of this stream but that's
not the point of this stream so I'm the
out to get into more detail of what
happened over the past two months while
I've been away which some of you may not
even know that I was away for two months
but I was away for two months huzzah
Here I am now and when I was in Austin
when we were filming the big project I
was not the worst thankfully I was not
the best either because I'm never the
best but I was pretty good I was pretty
decent so uh yeah it's uh more than a
vacation yeah I wait did someone say
send her a sorry meme under me that's
not that's not a currency you do for
that but yeah I'm the worst I'll get her
flowers or something or a present or
something nice either way but I've been
away in Austin for the past two months
and it's been really really really nice
being out for two months not just like
being away but just being able to work
on what we were working on basically uh
let me see let me see
so I've been away for two months working
on a big project over in Austin we've
been filming something for the past
month we've been planning it for the
past two months it is the biggest
project I have ever done it is the most
ambitious thing I've ever done
and holy crap do I have a ton of stories
about those adventures that we are in I
have to try to tell them in as minimal
detail as possible because I don't want
to spoil anything about the project that
we're working on because it's going to
be really really fun yes I know that a
lot of people make mistakes but this is
uh this is a big mistake
I just don't know how I did it like I
don't know how I got through so many
steps of not being able to be there when
I needed to be there like there was my
phone was on silent but I thought it
would ring if someone ringed enough like
shouldn't there be a feature if someone
calls you like ten times in a row it
should ring if it's on Do Not Disturb it
should bring that and then like I don't
I I literally I I'm not even like I
didn't hallucinate it I unlocked the
door I unlocked it I did and I know I
did but
apparently I real acht it because of
force of habit
so anyway it's like it's fine
Oh for those who don't know amy is my
girlfriend send her Cup pong I don't
know anyway so I I did all of these
things in Austin that were extremely
like educational and they were a trial
and I love like you guys know me I love
I'm not a masochist I swear to God like
I swear but I love those nights where
you have been working all day and you
were unbelievably exhausted by the end
of that day and you crawl into bed
barely able to make it in bed you don't
even take your shoes off you like slide
into bed from the bottom up and you just
pass out immediately I live for those
days those are the days that make me
feel like I'm really doing something
those are the days that make me feel
like I'm alive like I can accomplish
something and I can make something
happen and every day that we were
filming out there in Austin felt like
one of those days and you can't like you
can't understand how great that was how
great it was to be and I'm not like
preaching a culture of like working
until you're exhausted I do this because
it's my project it's like my baby it's
it's what I'm working on it
it's what I've planned for so long I've
been planning this for like a year now
and and just having it come to life and
come to fruition like that is it's it's
an experience that
it's such a purified version of purpose
it makes you feel like yes this is what
I was born to do this is what I was
meant to do this is what I live for this
is what I feel is it's just it's just
right and and every day that I was out
there I was filming this project it felt
like one of those times and and it was
crazy because you know I I wrote this
thing I was directing it which I've
directed things before in small settings
but this is the first time that I was
directing something with a huge crew
there with tons of people watching with
with we had 30 people on the crew and 30
people if you think like in a film crew
like for those of you don't know or
never been to film school like me I've
never been to film school that's I I
didn't even understand how 30 people
could be there and be working on
something but every person was essential
if anything there was not enough people
there like people moving the lights
people operating the camera people
operating the sound people taking making
sure that we didn't miss anything like
watching in the script that I wrote
garbage script that I wrote and watching
it for all the inconsistencies that we
were making up on the fly like this
stuff like it was amazing like it was
incredible I loved every part of it but
some of those experiences out there were
ungodly there was another time okay this
is uh this is just I'm gonna try to
dance around this story as much as I can
because it is it I can't not tell the
story but I'm hoping I can tell it
without the context so we were out in
let's say we were out in the woods right
we were out in the woods I don't know if
Amy sent me the picture of it I don't
think she did I would show you the
picture but we were out in these woods
towards the end of the shoot and it was
at night because we had to shoot some
things at night and they turned on a
big-ass light like a lighthouse version
of a light and they used to call this
place spider woods and they changed the
name because that name was too scary let
me tell you some spider woods is not an
exaggeration if anything it's an under
it's an under saturation it's under it's
under
saturated it's under exaggerated it's
it's anti exact what's the opposite of
exaggerated it's under it's under spoken
it's it's on its it's too what's the
word hey help me what's the word it's
under it's under exposed I'd like in in
exaggerated and the unn what's the word
what's the word for not exaggerated its
it's realistic its dub but it's um
what's the word what I it's uh it's on
understand understatement that's it
sorry I'm not peeking the mic I
apologize I've getting all over the
place oh it's an understatement
that's it so spider woods number one
spiders number two snakes Oh number
three because it's Texas number three
number three bugs in general because if
there's spiders there's things that
spiders are trying to catch and so and
so we didn't know this
cuz it's night you can't see the bugs
but when you turn on a big-ass light in
the middle of an empty field and it is
the only source of light in the entire
field it is a beacon for every single
bug every single insect everything that
flies to go to that light so we're
sitting in the middle of a field with
like an alarm calling in all the bugs
we've got Moss we've got flies we've got
mosquitoes because it was mosquito
season just smack in the middle of
mosquito season it is just like spiders
probably crawling through the breasts
that we can't see price snakes coming in
low light time for me to get over there
in the middle of nowhere with like one
we had a medic we had a medic on standby
but my god that was terrifying I wish I
had the picture if I have it all I'll
put it up on the community page or
Twitter or something
but it's just like a light and you can't
see the light for how many bugs are
there it is ungodly how many bugs are
there so that was just one night of
experience we had multiple night shoots
it was funny because we were out on a
scout for one of the locations and we're
just all talking about like no I think
we should go here go here and just like
we like someone's like oh a steak and we
all just looked down and like inches
inches from our feet is a just a solid
black snake and I don't know my snakes I
don't know if you guys know your snakes
but just in my mind if a snake is just
completely black I think black mamba and
that's probably wrong but I know Black
Mamba is bad because of Kill Bill I know
that's bad because of Kill Bill so I'm
like hmm I think that maybe maybe we
should get away from that thing so
everyone like I'm like and then the
whole crew is like oh do it like woohoo
like oh hey buddy so like there was just
like snake going through there and it
ran away cuz it's like probably scared
of us or something like that I don't
know why I could kill any one of us so
that was that was the first that was
like the first or second day that I was
in Austin Texas and that was just like
up oh hey yeah there's nature outside
you don't stay inside in here in a nice
closed box with no bugs and no snakes no
you're outside with the snakes and the
spiders and stuff and it wasn't just the
spiders that were bad we're at a
separate location that was more and not
tropical because obviously it's Texas
but more lush in terms of the forest
scape so we are literally in a pit
that is apparently the breeding ground
for every mosquito in that entire area
and I'm not joking when I say that when
I say this understand that I am not
exaggerating every mosquito comes from
this one place I we don't know this
going into it we don't know it scouting
it but when we go there to film when we
go there to film on the day we're
shooting I am wearing not long sleeves
not long pants I am in shorts and I am
in like cutoff sleeves to here and I'm
being filmed so like they got some
schmutz on me for like dirt and stuff to
match the look of where we came from for
what we're shooting which means they
can't spray me with bug spray because
know that'll that'll what make the dirt
all run and be weird-looking so we can't
have that so I'm sitting there in in the
middle of mosquito heaven and it's not
just me there's a there's another
youtuber who's there on the day that
we're there and we're filming together
and like he has even less clothes than I
do he's not naked don't don't get
excited this series doesn't have nudity
in it but he's wearing less clothes than
I am and he has a no bug spray neither
of us have any bug spray so like there's
actually the take we're gonna use in the
scene has me swat a mosquito out from in
front of me as we're filming and that's
the take we're gonna use because I
forgot that it happened it became such
an unconscious reflex just be like bad
but get out here like everywhere any and
this is such a trooper like I'm not
gonna tell you who it was because that
would also be a spoiler I wanna I want
that to be a surprise but man it was
just uh it was just so like awful it was
it was awful because also in that same
location and for those of you who have
like a weak disposition a weak stomach
or maybe you're eating right now you
might not want to watch this because
it's about to get gross so we're we're
there and it turns a night so it's dark
so we need to rig up a light again now
you know what I said about the light in
the field
well this is different because we're in
a pit
so we're lighting it from the top and so
what happens is given that we're in a
forest surrounding not only does that
call everything that flies and this is
why I know that later on when we let
that other light we were calling the
things that crawled it called the things
that crawled and the thing about a pit
is when the light is pointing into the
pit
that means everything jumps into the pit
and you know why we like things to
illuminate the person being filmed we
have a spotlight on us
that is a beacon calling every bug in
the forest to jump on us and it's just
it was just a nightmare cuz like as soon
as they turned it on we started hearing
this kind of like and we're like what
what the hell is that it sounded like it
was raining it sounded like it was
hailing like it was hailing where we
were and we're like what the hell is
that cuz I wasn't at the place yet where
the light was I was walking up to it
and when I get there it's crickets it's
crickets leaping off of this ledge to
get down to where we were and they're
just hitting the ground they didn't even
die like it didn't kill them like he
didn't kill them if they were fine like
it crickets were fine they're just like
and then jump away they it was raining
crickets it was like a thing it's like
it's like the locust swarms coming out
Nora raining frogs raining crickets and
it was like doosh it was just like oh my
god how can we shoot and we did we did
anyway because eventually the forest ran
out of crickets so we were doing our
best like we didn't want to like step on
crickets number one because gross and
number two because we felt bad because
we were calling them to their doom
basically we thought like once they got
into this pit they'd never be able to
get out so we were creating like a new
ecosystem for these crickets to get down
in this place and we're like I guess
this is their home now yeah I guess
that's just where they were and so like
it was just the weirdest most surreal
thing for us to be doing this because
number one I'm not used to that kind of
[ __ ] filming with a big crew I mean but
number two I loved it I loved every part
of that lady was so surreal and
experienced just because it was so like
when do you get to tell that story I I
can tell that story now and not be
making up a goddamn thing you can
corroborate that with every single
person who was there that day that that
[ __ ] happened that happened I don't like
I I there's one of the things I loved
about doing these things is the the
problem with like doing YouTube on a
daily basis is that you've run out of
life to tell like I want to share
everything I do with you guys as much as
I can without spoilers but I want to
share with you guys because like I love
telling you guys about my life and I
love being open with you guys and I love
discussing like my wants and my desires
and like things that I want to do and my
ambitions but when in the hell do you
get to do that and I'm so goddamn lucky
to be able to say that I can do that and
I can experience that and to be able to
do that and also work with a really
great team and be able to work with
really great youtubers and be able to
work with like people that I really
respect and admire and do it all so that
you guys can enjoy something that like
we tried and strived for and really
pushed ourselves to do is an amazing
feeling
it's something that you can't buy it's
something you can't pay for and it's
it's those moments that I will remember
for the rest of my life like I always
talked about how in YouTube like there
are moments that I look back in my
channel and I remember them very
distinctly because they're so like
integral to me finding out who I am like
they're so important for me discovering
like my personality who I'm gonna be
what I want to do like those moments I
look back on and I always always
remember and I'm so happy that I get to
do them and it's all because you guys
support what I do that's the only reason
that I'm able to do it I mean I'd do
something like that even if I didn't
have this channel are you guys out there
or or something like that it's you know
it's it's something that I can never
take for granted and it's moments like
that when the crickets are raining on my
head and there's mosquitoes everywhere
and I will itch for the rest of eternity
just because of that moment but at the
end of the day we'll have something that
you guys can really appreciate you guys
can like sink your teeth into and and
really like enjoy I think you know
that's what makes this whole YouTube
thing so special because in no other
circumstance would I be able to do that
in no other circumstance would I be able
to go out there with a crew have them
trust me as a director who's never
directed a big project before in his
life with a big crew I've directed a lot
of things now but trust me in a way in
an unknowable way like that's
that's amazing that's that's
unforgettable that's incredible and I
just have you guys thankful so sincerely
thank you guys for letting me do that
it's it's something that I can't repay
and the only way that I can repay it is
by trying to make sure that I always
push myself harder because you know for
a longest time there I thought that I
had like reached the peak you know
because I've got a bajillion subscribers
I've got like so much clout I've got of
whatever you want to call like I've got
the respect of my peers on this platform
and I've got all this I you know I
thought like I had everything that I
wanted cuz like I don't want a lot I
don't need a lot in my life I don't I
have more than enough and I I readily
admit that and it's but it's one of
those things where I could see like I
could see a little bit more for me to
learn a little bit more for me to try
and a little bit more for me to push
myself
it was a long time to get to that point
where I could kind of admit to myself
that maybe maybe I'm not done you know
maybe maybe I've got more to do maybe
I've got more two more to show the world
maybe I've got more to learn about
myself and that like to have that
certainty like I I literally can't
describe how valuable that is to me his
person to know that I've got more to do
because like I said before I'm the type
of person that wants to push himself to
the limit to see how far I can go and to
see how much I can do and to see what I
can do and and like now I know like I
really know that I'm not done you know
I'm not done with making things you know
I thought I was I wasn't gonna quit
anytime soon but like I've got I've got
more to give and I can't wait for you to
see this thing this thing that we've got
I'm not gonna spoil it damn thing about
it and this will probably be the last
time I've talked about it before it
she comes up but it's just so fun I want
to tell you guys so much about it but
there's so few things that I can readily
say I can say I can say one more I can
say one more thing okay I've got I've
got I've got one more story so okay let
me try to craft this in the way that is
not spoilery at all there there's
another there's another location that we
were filming at that was awful but in a
different way it combined every part of
awful from the previous stories that I
said into one location and then
sprinkled on top a new unique flavor of
awful that I've never experienced before
in my life Oh when's the release date
there's broad coming out in October
there's a lot of post-production that
needs to be done there's visual effects
that need to be done there's a lot that
needs to be done so we're looking around
I don't know probably not even October I
wouldn't expect this for we're gonna try
for this year that's the the one thing I
can promise like when I said this is a
big project this is a big project it's
like huge it's freaking enormous I
that's all I can say without spoiling so
if we get it in this year I'll be real
happy like you guys know how Damian I
talked about Damian like I planned that
back in the October October ish or
something like that like love last year
I planned that in actually No before
that I planned it in September of last
year and it took until about a month and
a half ago for us to actually come out
like I am NOT good about getting these
estimates so I would say if we can get
it in before the end of this year that
would be great
that would be wonderful
I don't know probably November I would
say that's a safer bet I don't want to
say December actually just ignore
everything I said as far as the date
goes and just make up one in your head
because that would probably be more
accurate than anything that I would say
but it's gonna come out so anyway new
flavor of horrible place this place not
only did it have it was in the middle of
a wooded area so you had the bugs and
you had the snakes and you add all the
other things that crawl in the grass and
we were shooting there both day and
night
but also this place is I don't think
it's a spoiler to say this this place
was
I'm just gonna say it's a decommissioned
sewage treatment plant so it's it's
discussed is December 31st 11:59 yeah
that's probably gonna be closer so it is
absolutely disgusting because let me
tell you about decommissioned that means
it was shut down and is no longer
operational
as of 2006 this place was decommissioned
13 years ago and you know you'd think
that in a place like that they would
flush all the pipes out and like get all
that sewage out of there no no no no
that that bad stuff that has been there
since 2006 2006 and so we me
specifically we we I don't have the
benefit of wearing a mask you know why
cuz I'm in front of the camera and I
can't do that but everyone behind the
scenes is wearing masks I'm wearing like
helmets and things like that and it's
just like it's so gross
but I mean the production value was like
it looked it looks great
be so grateful that technology has not
reached the point where you can smell
where it's filmed because that I can't
the smell is just indescribable and the
worst part about it is that I got used
to it I don't like that I got used to
that smell like okay great like it's
good to know that the human body is
capable of adapting to any almost any
situation readily and you know it
beautifully and stuff like that I'm so
that's really cool that it can do that
but I got used to the smell of 13 year
old sewage which means that it baked
into my body so deeply that it became
part of me that my body was like yeah
that's that's normal this is fine this
is fine there was a pipe it was like two
different there's three different pipes
one was for sludge one was for slime and
one was for like scum it was sludge
slime and scum and those are apparently
three different things in a sewage
treatment the 3 s's of the apocalypse
why are you here to torment me I've
already got snakes mosquitoes
I've got bugs I've got everything and
it's just like oh and oh my god
I didn't even tell you about the beaver
about the beaver we were this poor
beaver they this thing had died years
ago years ago we were in in this
building and we were like scouting out
really I'm like ok well come camera
we'll come in here I'll run in here I'll
do a crazy thing or whatever and then we
looked down at the corner because I'm
like maybe I'll stand in that corner and
I look down and there is just a dead
beaver like right there it had
apparently bit into like an electrical
cable or something like
that it had bit into one and it died
years ago and no one's noticed it
because this place was decommissioned in
2006 like the power still worked
unfortunately for the beaver fortunately
for the production but and and none of
us were gonna move it because that's not
our job so guess what I did I did the
shot standing two inches away from a
dead beaver and yes yes it did smell it
smelled that it was a new it was like an
aromatic add it on to the sewage
background of this place like if the
poor thing yes the poor thing like that
for beaver that poor beaver but also
couldn't it have done the cable
somewhere else like this why it's only
like yeah none of us are gonna move it
because we know that if we if we touch
it like it's gonna spring to life and
then lunge at one of our throats or
something like that zom zom beaver like
it's it's just like I'm not gonna mess
with that like that's that's not it's
not why we're here let's just get it
without disturbing it cuz it'll just
like it'll curse us if we even touch it
or maybe if we move it a little bit like
bugs and larvae we'll just like out of
it we don't want that visual in my life
I don't need that I have enough
nightmares as it is so we yeah so we
yeah we we got
and I felt so bad for the crew because
like it's like Dan this is this is my
passion project yeah this is my past
project I get to be all up my own ass
about how the art of it we need this
shot over here and oh we need to make
sure this looks this way and but verge
is like this is their day job right the
camera operator the boom operator the
other people looking behind even the
person just like running the craft
services table like this is their job
they have to live in this tube there
they have to live in this fur we were
there for like a week we were there for
a week we're just filming in this way
this was the longest place we were at a
single location than any other and the
poor crew like oh my god I want you guys
to send so much love to the crew because
they walked through a nightmare a living
nightmare every day every day for like
12 hours a day we were in a nightmare
and they did it and they did it and you
know I that's why I never complained a
single moment that I was there because I
can't complain I have no right to
complain I asked for this I asked for it
I wanted it this is what I wanted they
all can hate me but I cannot complain
and none of them complained not a one of
them complained they were so
professional about it they were so
delightful about it it was it was
beautiful it was wonderful like I'm so
grateful to these people for like
stepping up the way they did but my god
was that I will not write a location
like that ever again now I know huh
anyway yeah so that is all right just
have it I've just got a
this is so much so much to take in from
the past like forever man
but yeah so I am back home that's about
all that I might think of another story
as I'm still talking here but just like
that is like the majority of the stories
that I can share without spoiling so
just we'll leave it at that
I will there are tons of pictures I will
try to find pictures that are not
spoilery as well that I would like to
share but I will have to sort through
them as time goes by the other thing
that I want to apologize for here comes
another big big public apology here we
go big big admitting I'm the absolute
worst like here we go um I obviously
videos have nothing up to snuff this
past week and that's like my fault
my fault entirely because I not only
have I been back relaxingg trying to get
back into the swing of things because we
basically like moved out there for like
two months we we like packed up as much
as we could I packed up like a computer
itself and then to come over here so I
had to set everything back up and then
then I had to like talk with the
post-production people I have a meeting
immediately after this live stream with
post-production to talk with them about
it but just you know I've got tons and
tons and tons and tons of things that I
need to do but apology I have not been
getting videos up as they should be
getting up today basically I'm going to
be recording all day long I'm gonna be
recording getting tons of videos in the
pipeline so that I can get back up on
top of things and then things can be the
way they should be which is semi-regular
uh-huh you know me
the beacon of regularity that is this
guy I am consistent as the day's long I
am just there you know me you can always
count on a markiplier promise from the
day you're born to the day anyway so it
like I'm not beating myself up because I
that's the thing like yesterday like I
took a day off I did I I relaxed I
basically focused on stuff that I wanted
to focus on I like I took a nap I didn't
even worry about recording like I do
that like I worked
little freaking hard on this project and
I came home and I I wanted to keep up
with things but you know I needed a day
off so I needed to relax to that and
today like I've got a bunch of [ __ ] to
do but I'm gonna make sure that I record
because I want to and that's the most
important thing like that's what a lot
of people need to understand about me
specifically is that I want to I want to
do these things I want to I love it I
love working hard I love it but I only
love working hard if I have a purpose
behind it I only love working hard if I
feel like it's going somewhere and for
the first time in a long time
I feel like I'm going somewhere you know
and that's like it that can be weird for
you guys whoever might be hearing this
for the first time like it might be
weird to think that I would be not going
somewhere but if you've like been
watching my videos for the past couple
years you'll you'll see videos like I am
lost or like I I don't know what I'm
doing or I'll like I'll make a
late-night vlog or something like that
it's because like I don't know where I'm
going and without that like the the work
loses its meaning you know what I mean
it loses its meaning because there's no
real feedback for knowing where you're
going but for the first time in a long
long time I know where I'm going because
you know I've been doing this a long
time but not as long as some people and
I've been feeling you know the same
thing that a lot of people have been
feeling in terms of burnout and stuff
like that but I love working hard I love
making things I love telling stories I
love pushing myself I love like those
sleepless nights I love leaping out of
bed and not being able to wait to work
on the next project that I'm working on
I love that I live for that I live for
those moments and I'm so lucky because I
get another one some people in their
lives they don't even get one and I got
one when I started this channel seven
years ago when I started this channel I
got that feeling the feeling of knowing
that I was onto something the feeling of
knowing that I had a purpose the feeling
of knowing that what I was doing was
resonating with people what I was doing
was guiding people and pushing people
the
himself like that that was such an
amazing feeling at the beginning of my
channel and like I got real know people
are feeling at that it's like those
moments are fleeting those moments you
don't get forever you don't but I'm
lucky enough to now have a second one
cuz I love doing these big things I do I
love it I love it so much I love making
videos on YouTube
I love it I love it so much I love
trying new concepts and trying new
things and I love pushing myself because
it's has meaning it gives meaning to why
I'm here it gives meaning to my life cuz
I've always been of the mindset that you
know I only have so much time in my life
I will die someday and the only thing
that will be left behind when I dies is
the legacy I left behind the the
inspiration I gave to other people the
the the the things that I made those are
the only things that are gonna live on
beyond me so I have to make the most of
those things and like I just want to
make things I got get really tickled
about making things and I get really
tickled about thinking of things like
this whole week I've just been tinkering
with different things to work on for
next year's project like I've been I've
been looking forward to how this channel
is gonna turn out like I I feel like I
haven't been giving this YouTube channel
my full attention in terms of like
innovating on it like because because I
haven't known where it's going but now I
know where it's going now I see like the
goal at the end I have a goal to reach
now I see the horizon as far as it is
and I can I can get it like that's the
thing I believe that I can get it I
believe I can do that [ __ ] I believe it
and it's so cool like it's so cool oh
man it's so cool oh speaking of so cool
to two days ago my buddy my buddy John
and his girlfriend they took me out to
the the Griffith Observatory
here in Los Angeles and I've never
actually been I've never been and and we
we watched the demonstration of like
centered in the universe and it was just
lovely like IMAX style dome thing of the
night sky and like a narrative
walkthrough of the stars in space and
you guys know how much I love space but
it's like those things are the it's just
like so important to me to feel inspired
and it's so hard for me nowadays to feel
inspired because I've almost tapped
myself out on what I've done in my life
I've done so much that I feel guilty for
trying to do more but now I know I can
do more I know I directed a big project
with 30 people on it like I did that I
didn't do it perfectly but I learned so
much as I was doing it I can do it again
I can bring a vision of mine to life
like I made or I didn't make I helped
make Damien animated like cinematic
thing a short film that was like almost
fully animated it's like I'd like I had
an idea and it happened like that's the
craziest thing and I can do like gaming
videos where I have fun playing games
and trying to innovate on that concept
markiplier makes and stuff like that I
can do those things is so cool it's
really unbelievably cool I could I could
Yammer on for hours about how excited I
am about the future but I am excited
about the future and seriously like I
only have you guys to thank for it I
really do like I wouldn't be here
without you guys well I've said that a
bunch and you know it's it's a sentiment
that that's echoed across YouTube but I
don't think it's set enough because like
this this relationship between you guys
and me and the community as a whole is
what makes YouTube special
it's what differentiates it from
traditional media it's it's the kind of
thing that traditional media like
executives and people like that they
don't get they don't understand it
because it loses a sensibility about it
like to to traditional media the people
watching they are
and they can be nothing else like they
can be fans and they can understand
their fans but their objective is
completely different from our objective
their objective is is fundamentally
different and what that means is just
like they will never be able to
appreciate nor will they be able to
truly understand why these moments that
we have are essential like this
communication that we have this
connection that we have in the community
like all working towards a common goal
they they won't get that and I'm not
trying to be like oh just do fat cats in
the executives they don't get it but
it's it's true like this this moment in
time and this moment in history like is
special it won't happen again it may
change it may happen in a different way
but like this the way it is the first
steps to it like this won't happen again
and I want to appreciate it for I want
to appreciate it for what it is and when
it allows me to do right here right now
and I only have you guys to thank for
that so sincerely thank you thank you
thank you so much everyone for being
here with me we've got a long way to go
and we've got so many cool things on the
horizon but for right now the immediate
goal here's my plan everybody shush uh
here's my shut up here's my plan
I appreciate you now shut up there's my
grand sweeping but also thank you to
everyone that's been giving super chats
for that like astonishingly amazing
Thank You Julia gaming you did not need
to do any of that like everyone that has
been giving super Jets thank you so much
for that I'm sorry I've been missing it
because I've been so fat doing my own
head about it but here's my plan shut up
shut up everybody shush everybody shut
up I'm talking so here's my plan
immediate future get back on video
schedule that's number one here's my mid
New Year's resolutions it's it's almost
halfway through the year it might be
exactly halfway through the year mid New
Year's resolutions everybody write them
down because we're all gonna do this
together if you're gonna be part of this
community you're gonna
I'm sorry peeking if you're happy
partners community you will make amid
New Year's resolution alright
number one get back on these are not
promises I want to be very clear these
are you're not listening to me
these are not promises pay attention
stop hey you're looking away stop
shopping look at me these are not these
are not promises therefore I can't break
them these are not promises
hey who's who's uh here's a shiny knife
here's a shiny steak knife why is it in
my computer room don't ask questions
just look at the shiny knife alright so
number one get back on video schedule
get them back and get them regular
number two get on top of post-production
for this thing so that it doesn't take
that long to come out number three get
back on the member streams which I
haven't been doing and I apologize to
all the lovely members out there who
have not been getting your streams I've
just been so busy that I haven't been
able to do them but get back on those
I'm probably gonna do another one
tomorrow
number four let's keep it at three let's
keep it at three get back on schedules
keep up with post production
keep up with member stuff and number
four spread love and joy as far as the
eye can see
no it's unfathomable anything like that
but just in general I'm gonna get back
on my [ __ ] because my [ __ ] has not been
on my my my my schedule has not been
good I have not been keeping up with the
regular YouTube stuff which is it stuff
that really makes a difference in this
world so I am going to hit the ground
running with this whole YouTube [ __ ] I
sound like I said like I sound like a
guy who's like I'm gonna try YouTube you
know this YouTube thing uh it seems
pretty cool I'm gonna try it like I I'm
talking as if I don't have an enormous
YouTube channel shut up you're not
listening to me shut up
speaking I don't know why they're
speaking so much it shouldn't be shut up
hey I know I have a youtube channel I
remember I want to get I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna really hit the ground
running with this whole YouTube business
all those other youtubers better watch
out because it's about to go down it's
about to go down i'ma show them I'm I
want to be a big year two person that
was my original goal like stop it Julia
stop it stop it no need for that thank
you but stop it like that was my
original goal back when like for those
of you remember like you could dig up
the old vlog I was like I was like maybe
a thousand subscribers and I was falling
like now I see you like the school and I
remember like my mind so I was like I
think I think I want to do it I want to
be a big youtuber someday and it's like
that that's what I mean by when I I felt
like I accomplished my goals because it
like as a kid you know I was 22 so not
really a kid but I was 22 I think I want
to be a big youtuber someday you know I
think I think I want that I really would
like that and so I did that and now Here
I am again
saying I think I think I want to be a
big youtuber guys I think I want to be a
big youtuber again it's that weird for
me to say I do
I like I wanna I want to really like
take ownership of this again because I
have been coasting by on like being
complacent and that's the one thing
that's like completely opposite with the
person that I am is like I don't want to
get complacent like I'm really good at
what I do and I've got a lot of skills
like in my brain I they don't come out
of my brain perfectly but I've got a lot
of substance and I've got a lot of whole
spa and I got a lot of gusto and I can
do some things so like I want to hit
this [ __ ]
again I mean in a weird way I want to
show people that youtubers in general
can make really cool [ __ ] and youtubers
have been making really cool [ __ ] like
I've been super into like watching other
other youtubers now like again finally
for the first time forever I'm looking
at other youtubers for inspiration and
seeing all the amazing things that
people are making out there and then
there's all the garbage that people make
that we're gonna ignore for convenience
e-cig but there's so much more potential
about what youtube can be and I feel
like in my complacency I've kind of let
that slide so why don't we together make
one last number for you mid mid New
Year's resolution to really show the
world what we can do because I can do a
lot but the only way that it's actually
gonna do something of worth is if we all
do it together and I think that is a
really cool thing I don't know what
we're doing yet I don't know what we're
doing but hey it sounds pretty cool
right
so I am super excited about what the
future can do so just be ready be ready
for whatever strange bizarre ideas I
have because if there's one thing I do
it's come up with random [ __ ] ideas
that I will abandon within weeks but
those are gonna come way faster now I
think it's going to be a really fun time
and together we're gonna show some
people we're gonna show some people what
we can do
alright okay but but until we have a
tangible reason to stay like on the edge
of your seat like wait readily forget
the bail who needs the bail you just
guys always have my YouTube channel
opened up we're moving beyond the bail
we're innovating on the bail we're gonna
disrupt the bail the bells [ __ ] let
me tell you something about the bail
it's [ __ ] we don't need that bail
because you guys are just gonna be
waiting like ambush predators like a
spider on your nest the web webs they
don't have nests some have nests you're
gonna be a spider I don't care if you
have a nest or a web but you're gonna be
on the edge of it and you're just gonna
be ready at like my shell or like
wherever I am and just gonna be like um
I don't know what's gonna happen but I'm
ready so like don't be surprised when
things go weird don't be surprised yeah
you're gonna show the people how weird
it can get oh yeah oh hell yeah yeah
they'll be pretty cool anyway so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
gotta get out of here because I got to
get on a phone call for another meeting
about post-production stuff but just
thank you guys thank you so much for
being here with me thank you for
believing in me thank you for trusting
me and I can't wait to show you all the
cool stuff that I'm gonna do but thank
you guys so much
go have fun with the rest of your day
expect videos to come back tomorrow and
yeah just be ready don't leave for even
a moment because if you do I'll know oh
I'll know the bail works both ways I
know I know anyway thanks everybody so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you in the next video
but I bye guys bye